ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะทุกคน
เย้
ดีใจอะไรได้ค่ะตัวนักเรียนอาจจะรู้สึกว่า
เรียนภาษาไทยกับครูหญิงครูฟ้าเนี่ยเข้าใจ
คำว่าเย่
เท่านั้น
เนี่ยต้องเข้าใจว่าวันนี้วันอะไรด้วยวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะอ่ะอันนี้อะไรเนี่ยวันนี้วัน
พุธค่ะวันนี้วันพุธ
วันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะครูป๊าวันพุธที่ 23
ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ค่ะปีพศ
อะไรคะปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะคือฟ้าเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอังคารค่ะค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 22 ค่ะอยู่ที่เดือนเดือน 2
อยากได้เดือน 2 เหรอคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ค่ะ
ปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 เอสนศ.ปีคศ 2  022 ขอครูฟ้าอยากได้
22 เดือน 2 ปี
2022 ในหา 22 เดือน 220  222 บาทครูฟ้า
ชอบเลข 2 นะคะ
แล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 24 ค่ะจะเดือน
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงกี่รมงร์
เพลากี่โมงแล้วนะคะครูฟ้ามีละโมงแล้วนะ
กิโลโมงเย็นอะไรนักเรียนกี่โมงคะครูฟ้า on
นี้เวลา
11:00 นค่ะอะแล้ว 11 โมงกี่นาที
11:02
07:02 แล้วครูฟ้าตอนนี้ 11 โมงแล้ว
ครูฟ้ากินข้าวหรือยังคะ
ครูฟ้ากินข้าวแล้วค่ะโอ๊ะโอ๋
ดีมากค่ะกินข้าวแล้วเมื่อผู้หญิงล่ะคะผู้
หญิงกินข้าวหรือยังผู้หญิงยังไม่ได้กิน
ข้าวเลยค่ะครูฟ้าเอาผู้หญิงไม่หิวหรอ
หิวค่า
CC  OO แห่ไม่มีเวลา
สมัยต้องอัดวีดีโอสมัยอัดวีดีโอเศษมีเวลา
ประมาณ 30 นาที
ไม่อัดวีดีโอเนี่ยเสร็จมีเวลา 30 นาที
แล้วก็เสร็จก็มีคลาส
โน้ตออกสนาม 10 นาทีเนี่ยกินข้าวได้ไหมคะ
ครูฟ้า
ได้ดีคะผู้หญิงแต่ว่าทำอาหารเนี่ยใช้เวลา
นะหน้า 30 นาทีครูหญิงต้องทำอาหารแล้วก็
ต้องกินข้าวด้วย
โอเคหรออ๋อ 30 นาที
ทำอาหารยังไม่โอเคค่ะครูหญิงว่าฉันผู้
หญิงหรือจะต้องไปหาอาหาร
ที่เป็นอาหาร Fast  Food  in แตก
ถ้าไม่ชอบไม่ชอบแฮมเบอร์เกอร์ไม่ชอบ
Mcdonald ไม่ชอบ KFC อ่ะที่เป็นอาหาร
ฟาสฟู้ดช่วยหรือว่าอาหารที่กินเร็วๆไม่
ชอบของไทยไม่มีเหรอฟ้าของไทยก็มีอีอาหาร
ฟาสต์ฟู้ดอ่ะ
จริงหรอคะถ้าอยากจริงหรอคะ
ไก่
อกใครมีฟาสต์ฟู้ดด้วยหรอ
นี้ของไทย Fast  Food นะถ้านักเรียนหน่ะ
ไปเอากี่โทรศัพท์อยู่ไหนนะคะเจอไหมคะค่ะ
ไปไทยฟ้าสู้เนี่ยนะคะนักเรียนต้อง
ก็มันมันจะไม่เหมือน KFC สมัยไม่เหมือน
แมคโดนัลด์ไม่เหมือน
ไม่เมื่อไหร่คับเบอร์เกอร์คิงส์
ไม่ใช่อาหารไทยกับฟาสต์ฟู้ดแบบไทยเนาะทิ
เร็วๆเนี่ยนะคะมันจะร้อนๆหน่อยนี่ๆมัน
ต้องเป็นแบบนี้อันนี้ละกันไม่เห็นคนทำ
ด้วย
นี้นี่คือใช่ไหม
แบบนี้มั้ยคู่ฟ้า
โอ้โหนี่เลยอาหารตามสั่งงาอาหารตามสั่งก็
คือใคร Fast  Food นะคะนักเรียนคิดๆอยาก
กินอะไรก็บอกมันเข้ากับผมจำทำเร็วๆแล้วก็
กินเร็วๆต้องหาเห็นแมะอาหารปาสฟู้ดของไทย
ก็มีเป็นตาคำสั่งณวัน
นี้เนี่ยครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าก็เลยมีเมนู
อาหารตามสั่งที่คิดว่านักเรียนน่าจะเห็น
มากๆที่ถ่ายที่แบบเป็น Street  food ถ้า
พูดอย่างนี้ค่ะแล้วก็กินได้เร็วๆอร่อย
แล้วก็คิดว่านักเรียนเนี่ยกินได้ใช่ไหม
ไม่เผ็ด
เผ็ดเนี่ยถ้าถ้ามีมีพริกใช่ไหมบางอย่าง
เนี่ยมีพริกอันนี้คลิปนะคะ
เหมือนใบไม้เลยเผ็ดๆเนี่ยนักเรียนอาจจะ
กินไม่ได้ไง
มันก็เลยมีอาหารที่ไม่เผ็ดหรอกผู้หญิง
มากๆเนี่ยไม่เผ็ดแล้วก็ผู้หญิงคิดว่านัก
เรียนเนี่ยกินได้
เป็นเมนูอาหารตามสั่งหรือว่าฟาสท์ฟู้ดของ
คนไทยนะคะมีอะไรบ้างล่ะผู้หญิงอยากดูมาก
นี่ค่ะครูฟ้าอันนี้เราเรียกว่าอะไรคะอัน
นี้เราเรียกว่าผัดกระเพรา
นี่ก็กูทราย
มีแต่ผัดกระเพราเนี่ยอุ่นๆมีพริกสมัย
เนี่ยพริกพริกเผ็ด
เผ็ดมั้ยไม่เท่าไหร่ค่ะกูคายอ่ะเห็ดนิด
หน่อย
หรือว่าถ้านักเรียนอาจไม่ชอบก็บอกว่าไม่
ผิดไม่ผิด
แปลบอกว่าเอาผัดกระเพรา
ไม่เผ็ดค่ะ
ไม่ผิดเนาะผัดกระเพราเนี่ย
คำเปลวจะไม่กินเร็วมาเป็นแล้วก็อร่อยใช่
ไหมคะอร่อย
ผัดกระเพราก็จะมีผัดกระเพราหลายอย่างที่
ไม่ผู้หญิงนี้มีมีไหมผัดกระเพราหมู
อ่า
โอเคค่ะผัดปลาคอ
ผัดกระเพราไก่ได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะโอเค
ผัดกระเพราเนื้อ
โอเค
เหนือนี่ก็คือเนื้อวัวนะเนื้อวัวเนี่ยคน
ไทยพูดสั้นๆเนื้อนะกะเพราเนื้อ 1 เนื้อ
กระเพราปลาได้ไหมคะกระเพราปลาโอเคนะคะ
โอเคโอ้
กับเขากุ้ง
อันนี้เขาพักหรือมาก
ผัดกระเพรากุ้งโอ๊ยก็เพรากุ้งก็โอเค
เคหะ
กระเพราปลาหมึกโอเคไหมคะโอเคเลยกะเพราปลา
หมึกคนไทยชอบกินนะคะกระเพราปลาหมึก
เคยหญิงผู้หญิงน่า
รักจ้าวหัวใจยังไงคะอย่างนี้ก็เขาก็หมึก
ชาคุหญิง tops มามาก
แล้วก็กระเพราปูได้ไหมคะ
ได้นะกระเพราปูโอเค
พัทยากระเพราปูอร่อยมากนะคะที่พัทยา
จ่ายใส่แต่ว่าถ้าสมมติว่าครูหญิงเนี่ย
อยากกินกระเพรากุ้ง
กะเพราปลาหมึก
กระเพราปู
แล้วก็กระเพราปลาด้วยกันโอเคไหม
โอเคนะเออโอเคก็ต้องตอบผัดกระเพราซีฟู๊ด
ใช่ไหมคะใช่ยาหรือว่าผัดกระเพราทะเล
ทะเลก็จะมีลามีไม่มีไม่รู้นะแต่ว่าจะมีมี
กุ้งมีปลาหมึกนะนี่รนด์กระเป๋าทะเล
ผัดกระเพราเนี่ยเป็ดกินได้เร็วๆนักเรียน
ชอบอะไรชอบหมูชอบไก่สอบกุ้งก็บอกได้
ไทยค่ะเห็นไงพักพุธฮาฮะเปล่าค่ะ Fast
Food ไงนี่คือช้อนพูดอะไรอ่ะต่อไปค่ะนี้
ก็เป็นฟาสต์ฟู้ดที่
ครูฟ้าชอบนะคะอันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะอันนี้
คือข้าวไข่เจียวน้องอันนี้คือข้าวนะคะ
แล้วก็นี้ก็ไข่เจียว
อันนี้
อร่อย
อร่อยแล้วก็ง่ายมากงูไอ้ห่าเออคือขยะนัก
เรียนได้จะรู้จักไข่เจียวนะคะเวลาเรียน
นักเรียนที่จะรู้จักใช่ไหมค่ะเธอคือใคร
ไข่ผู้หญิงเมื่อกี้นี้มึงจะไปโดนนะคะนี่
ค่ะไข่ใช่ไหมไข่
ดีนะๆแล้วก็เดี๋ยวเจียวแล้วก็
วันนี้ก็ได้นักเรียนก็ไปหาได้นะครูหญิง
กับครูฟ้านะมีวีดีโอทำไข่เจียวหรู
แล้วก็นี่นะข้าวไข่เจียวเนี่ยใช้เวลาทำ
นิดหน่อยแล้วก็กินง่ายๆอร่อยอีกนะอันนี้
ก็เป็นฟาสต์ฟู้ดของคนไทยเนาะข้าวไข่เจียว
นะคะคือแบบอันนี้คือฟ้าอันนี้อะไรคะอัน
นี้ข้าวผัดค่ะข้าวผัด
จริงๆข้าวผัดนักเรียนก็ชอบกินใช่ไงเพราะ
ว่ามันไม่เผ็ดเข้าผ่านเห็นอ้ะมันไม่มีไม่
น้ำพริก
ติ๊กเป็ดมากไม่ใส่พริกในก็ผัดนะก็นัก
เรียนก็เลยจะชอบเพราะว่ามันไม่เผ็ดจะไม่
แล้วเค้าสัตว์เนี่ยเหมือนผัดกระเพราไหมคะ
ก็คือถ้าครูหญิงอยากกินไม่อยากกินข้าวผัด
หนีไม่ใช่ไหมโอเคค่ะข้าวผัดหมูโอเค
ข้าวผัดไก่
ข้าวผัดไก่โอเคโอ้
ข้าวผัดเนื้อ
เข้าผัดเนื้อก็โอเคมักไม่เห็นเฮ้ย 7 นะ
โอเคนะคะนักเรียนอยากกินเหใช่ไหมโอเคเขา
ผัดมาโอเคค่ะเคยป่า
เข้าผัดกุ้งก็คือเยอะๆนะข้าวผัดกุ้งกุ้ง
เอาข้าวผัดปลาหมึกโอเคมั้ยโอเคเข้าให้แต่
ละบุคคลกูข้าวผัดตรี
ข้าวผัดปูนักเรียนดึก Witch อะไรวาดข้าว
ถูกปูแต่แพงนะถ้า
ข้าวผัดหมูใช่มั้ยข้าวผัดหมูอาจจะสี่สิบ
บาทสมมตินะน่ากินข้าวผัดหมู
สวัสดี 40 บาทปูปูก็อาจจะเก็บ 10 คุยก็
คิดว่า 80 เหมือนกันอันนี้ปู
ปูข้าวผัดหมูเพราะว่ากูหนังปูเนี่ย
แพงนะๆ
ไม่ชอบเขาบอกว่าข้าวผัดไข่
หรอเข้าคะได้โอเคก็คือไม่ใส่เนื้อสัตว์
ค่ะใช้คือใช่มั้ยใส่หมูในใส่ไก่ไม่ใส่
เนื้อไม่ใส่ปลาไม่ใส่กุ้งไม่ใส่ปลาหมึก
ไม่ใส่ปูไข่เท่านั้นข้าวผัดไข่โอ้โหนะคะ
เล่นก็คัน
แล้วก็มีกี่มิติอีกนะครูฟ้าอีกหนึ่งเมนู
วันนี้ครูฟ้ารู้ไหมคะอะไร
หมูทอดกระเทียมหรอคะใช่ค่ะอันนี้เป็นหมู
เนาะหมูหมูทอดกระเทียมหรือว่าหมูกระเทียม
หอมอีกไม่ได้มีรูปกระเทียมให้นักเรียนดู
เสริฐเอาก็ได้ครับผู้หญิงใจหนูกัดเตรียม
นักเรียนอันนี้ก็เป็นเมนูที่อร่อยเพราะ
ลูกค้าชอบกินกระเทียม
ไม่ชอบอยู่ให้กินเมนูนี้ถ้าผู้หญิงไม่ชอบ
กระเทียมนี่เนาะกระเทียมน้องเป็นหมู
กระเทียมหรือว่าหมูทอดกระเทียม
ก็
จะจะว่านะถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยนักเรียนบอกว่า
นักเรียนไม่ชอบกินหมูใช่ไหมหมูทอด
กระเทียม
ไก่ทอดกระเทียมได้ไหมคะไก่ทอดกระเทียมก็
ได้ค่ะค่ะ
เนื้อทอดกระเทียม
ได้
ปลาทอดกระเทียมได้
กูอันนี้อร่อยกุ้งทอดกระเทียมอร่อยว่า The
Best สิ่งหลักลงกุ้งทอดกระเทียมปลาหมึก
ทอดกระเทียมได้มีก็อร่อยค่ะอร่อย
กูโทษกระเทียม
ขี่มั้ยไม่เคยเห็นนะเอาไม่เคยเห็นครูหญิง
ก็ไม่เคยเห็นน้องปูไม่มีแล้วก็เวลาคนไทย
กินหมู The  Toys กระเทียมไก่ทอดกระเทียม
สมัยเราก็จะกินกับไข่ดาวไหมกูฟ้า
ถูกต้องไข่ดาวไม่ต้องมีใครดาวเสาร์นี้ไข่
ดาวอันนี้ก็เป็นอ่าฟาสต์ฟู้ดแบบร้านอาหาร
ตามสั่งมันก็คือนักเรียนคิดอยากกินอะไรก็
บอกแต่มันจะมีอีกอย่างนึงที่มันไม่มี
Choice ไม่มีสอยถ้านักเรียนเห็นเขาจะขาย
1 อย่างเหมือนเบอร์เกอร์คิงอย่างเงี้ย
ถ้าคุณไปเบอร์เกอร์คิง Burger  King ก็มี
แค่เบอร์เกอร์
ไหมถ้าครูฟ้าอยากกินทอดก็ไม่ได้ต้องไป
เบอร์เกอร์คิงใครเนี่ยไม่โดนอ่ะโง่หรือ
ว่าต้องไปจ่ายค่ะไทยก็มีน้องไม่ใช่อาหาร
ตามสั่งนะแต่เป็นฟาสต์ฟู้ดเหมือนกัน
ฉะนั้นก็จะมีอันนี้นะคะอันนี้เราเรียก
อะไรคะคือฟ้า
ข้าวหมูแดงค่ะอันนี้เนี่ยทำมาจากหมูนะ
ครับหมูข้าวหมูแดงไม่มีข้าวไก่แดงเข้า
เนื้อแรงไม่มีไม่มีนะคะอันนี้หมูเท่านั้น
แล้วหมูข้าวหมูแดงแล้วอันนี้ล่ะเค้าครู
ฟ้า
เข้าหูกรอง oe อร่อยหรอหมูกรอบ
อันนี้ก็หูอย่างเดียว
[เพลง]
แล้วก็อันนี้ล่ะเค้าคือฟ้า
ข้าวขาวหมู
อันนี้เนี่ยเป็นข้าวตรงนี้นะคะตรงนี้ใช่
ไหมขาหมูเนี่ยขาขานะข้าวขาวหมู
อร่อย
ขาไก่ได้ขาหมูเท่านั้นหมดแล้วคะภูฟ้าถ้า
กดเเล้วนี้อะไรคะอันนี้เค้ามันไก่เอามัน
ไก่ก็คือไก่ไก่ Only ไก่เท่านั้นข้าวมัน
หมูไม่มี
ข้าวมันเนื้อไม่มีนะคะเป็นข้าวมันไก่
แต่ข้าวมันไก่มี 2 แบบนะมีข้าวมันไก่แบบ
นี้ไปต้มไก่ต้มใช่ไหมกูฟ้าเข้ามันไก่ต้ม
แล้วก็แล้วก็หนูข้าวมันไก่ทอดอันนี้เป็น
ข้าวมันไก่ทอดเนาะครูฟ้าชอบอันไหนคะข้าว
มันไก่ทอด
หรือข้าวมันไก่ต้มครูฟ้าชอบอะไร
กูพาชอบข้าวมันไก่ต้มมาอ่ะจะชอบแบบนี้
เนอะเรามันไก่ต้มแม่จะมีซุปใช่ไหมค่ะมี
สู่ว่าด้วยเรื่องว่าจริงข้าวเก่าข้าวมัน
ไก่ต้มเนาะข้าวมันไก่ทอดเป็นอาหารแบบ
ฟาสต์ฟู้ดของคนไทยนะคะถือว่าเราได้อาหาร
จานด่วนน้องฟ้าไทยฟาสต์ฟู้ดอาหารจานด่วน
เนี่ยที่นักเรียนเนี่ยชอบกินไทยมันเร็ว
ให้นักเรียนโรงเรียนมีเวลา 30 นาทีเห็นก็
กินกินได้ค่ะอ่ารีบแล้วก็ล๊อคแล้วก็ไม่
เผ็ดสมัยไม่เผ็ดอันนี้มีมีพริกใช่ไหมคะ
แต่ไม่เผ็ดโอเคเด็กๆสมัยเด็กๆเนี่ย 3 ขวบ
4 ขวบกินได้นะคะกินได้เอาข้าวมันไก่
นี้ครูฟ้า
ถามที่เราพูดมาเช้าเนี่ยนะอาหารอาหารไทย
ที่กินเร็วคุณครูฟ้าชอบอะไรมากที่สุด
ดูฟ้าชอบ
ใจมันก็จะมีอ่ามี
ผัดกระเพราใช่ไหมข้าวไข่เจียวทอดกระเทียม
ผัดเข้าหมูแดงข้าวหมูกรอบ
ข้าวขาหมูข้าวมันไก่ต้มแล้วก็เข้ามันไก่
ทอดครูฟ้าชอบอะไรมากที่สุด
พูดโอ้เยอะจังเลยฟ้าชอบมีกระเพรากุ้งกับ
ไข่เจียวขอคิดก่อน
เพราะคิดว่าฟ้าเรื่องข้าวไข่เจียวค่ะเออ
กูไปเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเลือดข้าวข้าวไข่เจียว
ไข่เจียวผู้หญิงชอบอะไรอ่ะมากที่ผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงชอบเอากระเพราค่ะ
กระเพรากระเพราหมูกระเพราไก่กระเพรากุ้ง
กะเพราปลาหมึกโอเค
นักเรียนชอบอะไรน้อก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้
นะคะส่วนมานี่เราสองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนเนาะ
คิวแล้วนะคะบางสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ